founded code value with 10 architects
wow and yeah from the very first day
and people just joined just wanted to be
part of this group
this elite group
wanted to do wonderful project and also
customers came because they knew that
they will get
the best solution
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
welcome to 20 minute leaders today i'm
with alon flice and we're going to be
talking about architecture software and
everything in between
alone is a global authority on multiple
technologies and platforms cloud
computing windows internals c plus
windows programming dot net with c-sharp
or c-plus plus he is the co-author of
the windows 7 microsoft training program
and the books introducing windows 7 for
developers published by microsoft press
for his proven expertise in community
leadership alon was awarded microsoft
regional director and microsoft most
valuable professional status as a result
alone is an in-demand speaker on these
subjects at major international
conferences such as tech at europe tech
ed usa ndc and more
beyond heading up most of code value's
complex strategic consulting and
development projects alone is a code
college top faculty member bringing to
the job many years of training
experience both in israel and abroad
alon received his bsc in electrical and
computer engineering from the technion
israel's prestigious institute of
technology
[Applause]
[Music]
i've been searching for people that are
truly happy with what they're doing and
innately they're excited about what
they're doing and i i i can't think of
that many people that where i look at a
profile like yours and your background
and the things that you do in the day to
day and the things you've done and the
companies built now that really embodies
the true passion of yours and i want to
start over there before we even get into
code value and what you've done as the
chief architect of many organizations
talk to me about this passion of yours
software
so i started to program when i was a kid
i think i was the first person in my
small town i live in binhamina and i was
the first high-tech guy when i was young
in binhamina
um
i think i started when the
first
personal computers arrived to israel i
have uh
the the first computer that i started
was the zx80
um of
sinclair and then i i bought this this
is some you know a machine that they
found
in one place and i started to code and i
liked it so much so i bought
i asked my parents to buy me
um the commodore vic-20
it was a 5k
uh computers you have three and a half k
for to do your programs and i started to
do basic but i saw that
it went too slow
so i was like 12 and i moved to to
develop using assembly
of the uh
it was an 8-bit computer
and
this is where my love to to code and
program began
and since then this is what i do
um
so um
i i moved from you know from the 8-bit
to 16-bit and 32-bit
uh
used to use
commodore omega and then moved to
unix the one the operation that came
before the linux
and from unix to windows
um i started my first
actual
job
uh when i was
a student in detecting but started to
work was
using windows 95
and then i moved to windows nt
and to the internal of windows
when i could see the engineering of the
operating system
and this is where you know started to
when you see um
and great stuff and and you dig into the
system you understand the system this is
where you start to love
uh the system the architecture of the
system
and it took me to
you know i used to be
a non-microsoft guy
and once i started to use the internal
of windows i became a microsoft guy so
and um
um
so it was like
to developer but also to understand the
system
and since i love to share and i love to
talk
i started to speak about like everything
about software about systems
and this is how i became speaker
um
and um
and
you know the combination of uh
uh
what you love to do and the combination
of sharing what you do um i think maybe
what i am today
uh i still
uh
still speak and still and and continue
to to
to get into the details to understand
the system to understand requirements
and to build architecture of the system
and nowadays it's much it's
in one hand it's much more complex
because you have so many
requirements and you need to serve so
many different uh customers and the
scale is huge it's internet scale it's
cloud scale
so in one end it's much more complex in
the other hands you have all the
facilities you have
um and many different kinds of
technologies you have the cloud with so
many services
so you can build this system
which are more complex in one hand but
then you have more tools to build them
phenomena um and this is actually what i
what i'm doing today you know
going back to
you developing as an engineer and here
i'm trying to distill
what transition you've made from being a
software engineer a developer to being a
leader right and it sounds like there
were a few things along the way but one
thing that that i was hearing is a theme
is this question is this idea of
progress right that the the world
progressed technologies progressed and
you yourself progressed with them
and you became
a deep
having a deep understanding of these
technologies that are emerging and where
they're headed talk to me a little bit
about that
that aspect of your personal growth
yeah when you start
um you need to learn a lot because
usually you start and there is the kind
technologies that you somehow need to
gain all the knowledge in order you know
just to become a developer
for me i was lucky because i started
when the first uh personal computers
came
uh came to me and i you know could go
with them go with the technology
um
even though you know there were
computers from the 50s and the 60s there
were there were mainframes and for me
when i was a kid is to look at these
machines and try to understand what are
those missing how you you work with them
for new developers today they need to
learn so many different technologies you
know just to get started so so i was
lucky
and since i really like to know how
things work you know not just the
abstraction not just use the software or
use the uh um
the sdk the stuff the development kit
all the language but also understand how
it how it was built how things worked
i was uh into the details from the first
uh um
from for my first uh learning um
uh
and um so if we'll take for example
um
after you know using basic and and
an assembly i moved to c and then to c
plus plus
and c bus was very young uh uh
programming language when i started
and then in 2000 i moved to dot net
and c sharp from the
beta version of c sharp and dot net from
the very beginning and any new release
you just learn you know just the delta
just what was added to the release so
again it's much easier
than to get into something and you need
to learn you know from now and backward
um
of course there are some
times that you need to learn also the
history and everything because if you
get into new technologies that you get
that you didn't do before
like for me is is uh using web
technologies for example so i used to do
html back then when you when there was
no
blogging systems you just had your html
page
incredible but nowadays if you want to
do something you know you need to learn
react and angular and all this stuff so
yeah there are some sometimes that you
feel like a beginner because you need to
get into new technology but
even though you get into new
technologies there are many things which
are just the same so
you learn something you see yeah this is
some somewhere similar to other
technology you just need to to learn the
different tiny things but you know how
to use it and you have a very good
understanding of how things work so
again
it's easier to
to grasp new technologies
but
the places that i have the expertise
which you know an expert is somebody
that knows everything about nothing
so
the the areas that i have the expertise
is
those areas that i just grew with them
like windows internals like uh c plus
plus like dot net c sharp
um
um the cloud you know started when uh
aws and azure just started and so you
again any every release you uh study
about the new release even though
today's there are so many different
services so you cannot know everything
and there are areas that you just know
about them you know a bit that you can
talk about them but you are not in the
details like for me
something that i really want to know but
i just play with is like machine
learning and ai which is another field
another area that you need
to get into the details so i can use
them but i'm not you know consider
myself as an expert in the area but now
is that the transition that you've made
personally from saying okay i'm going to
go into the internals and i'm going to
be able to speak about the ins and outs
and the zeros and the ones and
understanding that okay now i'm actually
going to have the super power of
understanding a lot of technologies
understanding their pros and cons and
being able to delegate also
responsibility and finding the right
people to be able to dive into those
zeros and ones
right
so when you become an architect
you cannot understand everything but you
you at least need to understand the
abstraction layer you need to pick the
right solution the right service for the
job
so you need to know the um
after architectures is made from many
different components you need to know
the
uh properties of the components and you
need to know how you need to connect the
different components together and you
need to know the properties of the
connections of the components but
it doesn't matter which you know system
you build even if you build a car or
building there are components that are
somehow connected and the properties of
the connection and the component so this
is architecture and if you want to be a
good architect then you need to
understand
or you need to know many different tools
and you need to know how to pick
the right tool for this for the uh
the requirements that you need to
fulfill
one thing which is i don't know if don't
know if it's good or bad i think it's
bad in software is that even if you
write a bad software it will work
but it will not work good
so
you order a pizza
uh
ten times you know you succeed order but
then in the 11th time then you get
please reorder
and something is wrong though somebody
didn't
pick the right tools or didn't use the
tool in the in the right way well you
know in this example specifically it's
pizza but you know we have a whole
netflix document documentary on boeing
and it's a little bit of a different
story
right
right so so yes so
when i teach about software architecture
um
i teach about
all those quality attributes
uh our reliability security privacy
scalability
uh um
all the different concerns that you know
you can it doesn't matter what you build
it's the concern that comes in any
system
um and i build not just
about these qualities but also how to
get this and how to use the tools to get
these qualities
that make your software much better
and
and uh
one of the thing is that um um when you
start usually you just want to do the
mvp right you you want to have the
minimal viable product the minimum
system that you can build
and many startups they just do like this
kind of quick and dirty job let's just
have something that we can sell
and the problem with this startup is
when they succeed when they have the
success then they have the problem
because the system is not built
with these qualities they cannot scale
their problem of security and stability
and today with the cloud
uh
you can build using the same effort the
same time but choosing right you can
build
systems that can scale and that can have
much better qualities just by using the
right architecture and picking the right
tools
and i think this is something that you
know you know for me when i uh when i do
the analysis of this kind of project and
i talk with the
uh um with startups and with uh um
junior developers
um
you know this is my passion how to uh
tell them what to do and how to assist
them with building a system that will
last that will have these
great qualities without you know putting
much more effort just by choosing right
incredible tell me about code value
so
code value we founded code value about
uh 12 years ago wow um yeah
and we wanted to build a place
for developers and architects that they
will feel like
it's you know that they are not coming
to work
they are coming to do what they love to
do
one of the problem with the high tech
and maybe today's is less
maybe today you can find other places
that uh our the same approaches as our
approach but
back then
if you want to
uh proceed with your
career usually you have to become a
board a project manager team leader
somebody that most of the time sits in
meetings and not
you know doing actual coding and and and
architecture and buildings building
systems
and we wanted to have a a home for this
kind of people the people that still
wants to
to to stay professional
to to do what they love to do
uh a home that if they say something
somebody else will listen to them you
know they will not need to fight for the
for the right to do the right thing
um and also for young developers that
want to become this kind of person you
know this kind of architects and and uh
senior developer
uh and this is why you build uh code
value we founded code value with 10
architects
wow and yeah from the very first day
and people just joined just wanted to be
part of this group
this elite group uh wanted to do
wonderful project and also customers
came because they knew that they will
get
uh the best solution
um
used with with with us with
these
professional architects and developers
so this was the base of code value and
you know from there we
uh continue to grow uh we uh we go with
you know people but also with different
uh areas
um
we started when they went when i when we
started and we and we came to companies
we told them
we think that you need to be
to uh to use the cloud for example they
ask us what the cloud what is the cloud
why do you think that we need to be
there today you know it's obvious
unless you have a very good reason not
to be in the cloud you're in the cloud
it's same with was with mobile
so we wanted to be a mobile first cloud
first
and we always look at new technologies
because we know that our people like to
uh to use
the best and you to be first that uh uh
you know that use the technology but
also with caution because you don't want
to use something which is
halfway baked or might not be a success
so you know always the cautious but but
but yeah but to to to use the the best
tools and the new tools
and
um and and this would happen we we now
have people that
um that there are web developers and
backend cloud developers we do a lot of
iot um solutions
uh we are multi-cloud companies so we
build also for aws google amazon
um
yeah so
now looking
at you know your journey until now and
obviously code value is a is a huge
company and you're doing front of all
things
if you look at your passions today
and you know going back to the theme of
growth and how you grew as an as an
engineer and an architect and a leader
where is the passion today the passion
is still with they say mentoring
it's you know not just learn you i
every day i learn new stuff probably
also forget some but every day you learn
something but it's not just learning
it's also to share what you learn and to
share your experience
so i learned you know by doing stuff i
learned also by looking at other
systems that other people
built you know for good and bad
sometimes you even learn more from you
know that you see something which is
wrong
um but also to share and my passion
today is not just to share my knowledge
with uh
um with this senior developers and other
architects and starter company companies
but also with junior developers
i think that our mission today
is
to
somehow fill the gap of taking new
junior uh journal developer that just
finished uh um any kind of study you
know you have boot camp you have
universities you have college
colleges
and they are not ready to get in you
know to start their work when you when
you uh
when you ask somebody to get a junior to
his team
usually they will say that they can't
use the
they can't have the junior because it
will take more time and more effort
because you now need to assign somebody
from the team to
mentor this uh
junior and um
and you will not get the productivity
that you need
but i think that with the right
mentoring before or during the studies
or just after but before starting the
actual uh
employment
um you can uh by
applying by by
providing the means of how you use the
tools
how you
become part of a team
how you get a task and you fulfill the
task how you can learn by yourself you
know instead of going to somebody and
and
interfere with their work
um
and provide this mentorship
so they can start in a much better
uh you know better level of uh
of knowledge and expertise and this is
something which today i'm passionate and
this is one one of the thing why i am
a microsoft mvp you know um
most very professional go to the
community speak with the community but
today i want to focus also uh not with
the you know uh
um expert and and uh
senior developer which usually what this
is what i used to do because i'm an
architect you know i talk in this
level now i try to talk in this level
and somehow fill this gap because we are
missing so many different developers we
are missing like 50 000 developers today
in israel
incredible
incredible just incredible and alone i
think that
the way you're talking about you know
your own journey coupled with code value
and where you are today and this idea of
mentorship and mvp
it's a
it's really
it's it's really awesome for me to hear
and it's it's just it's inspiring and
it's refreshing meeting people that are
so excited about what they're doing and
so passionate about it and building
incredible products and incredible
companies and i really want to thank you
for your time and your energy i learned
a lot and thank you for coming on the
show thank you and stay safe and stay
healthy and best of luck with code value
thank you
[Music]
you